hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
and today's hooter be a little bit
different I do want to talk about my
thoughts on the Battle pass a lot of
youtubers have been kind of sharing
their thoughts and it makes a whole lot
of sense this is something totally
unique too for honor not really
necessarily unique to the gaming scene
but unique to this game in particular so
people are going to have a lot of
thoughts about it and from what I've
been hearing the community has been
rather vocal whether that be positive or
negative about this so I wanted to share
my two thoughts and kind of what how I
feel about this battle pass we're also
gonna be breaking this up into two
sections the first part is gonna be
really dedicated to what is within the
past what I think is good what I think
is bad what can be changed and other
opinions like that with the second part
of the video talking about the
mechanical side the gameplay perspective
of it are these tears you know easy to
earn and how is the gameplay affected in
the battle past is this a grind etc all
that stuff is gonna be detailed with
this video so first up I actually wanted
to mention what was in the entire battle
past not these numbers could be wrong
there's over a hundred things in this
battle passed between the premium and
free version so it was really hard to
keep track of how many things there were
and if I lost track I'm I do apologize
but at least it's pretty close to the
actual number if I end up do getting it
wrong but for the totals we have 2800
steel 12 XP boosts 1100 Salvage 10 days
of champion status 26 weapons executions
and ornaments as well as 26 signatures
three or four different paint patterns
and I believe three or four different
emblems now of course there's a lot more
math involved with that because every
single character is getting each of them
so technically you could consider it 26
and then times four for the uniqueness
but we're just talking about specific
envelopes not how many of those emblems
in total and then to end it we also had
one battle of what I believe in two
outlines so right off the gate that's a
shitload of content now of course in
terms of a numerical value that's a lot
but in terms of its actual value within
the game and how much we're gonna use it
that's a totally different story now
I've been playing a lot of games that
have battle passes Call of Duty
fortnight apex you know for honor and a
bunch of other games that have kind of
adopted this to their I believe even
Rainbow six is starting to do it
or has had done in the past a lot of
games are adopting this style and my
favorite thing to look forward to in
every single battle pass a game that I
play is the tier 100 reward that's
supposed to be the highest thing pretty
much the main thing that you are
grinding to for about 90% of the time
that you're actually grinding the battle
pass and certain games do this well by
adding a very very unique weapon with a
really cool skin halo I believe did this
with the haunted helmet that not many
people used back in the day and what for
Honor's was was technically an outline
now of course you could pair that with
the Wulin executions I stated I believe
in a past video and on stream i don't
like grouping the executions like that
i'm just gonna put them at tier 99
because really they should be grouped
together but either way they're pretty
much the second-last reward because the
outline in itself is really the tier 100
and that's one of my complaints about it
is because we have an outline at tier 2
which kind of looks similar to an
already-existing outline we have I still
don't know what the name of it is but I
know that there's something pretty close
to it and the tier 100 is a little
closer to the tier 2 outline and either
way regardless of what you think about
it I still think the outline is really
cool it's not gonna be something I use
but I really don't think that it
deserves to be the tier 100 reward I
think that was really saved for the
executions and they all should have been
in a group together now what I actually
thought was a pretty decent idea that a
lot of people on stream also agreed with
is that we changed the outline on tier
100 to be animated the very first
animated unique emblem outline that
we've ever had in the game and that is I
think deserving enough to be a tier 100
a lot of people were saying that there
wasn't enough uniqueness or new things
added this is one of them it justifies
the cheer 100 that being an outline and
then that blue kind of streaks and the
wings of the dragon could be glowing and
kind of pulsing in different colours or
stuff while you're playing obviously
it's not going to show up on your chest
because I know you could put the emblem
on your chest maybe it could but I think
that's a bit too far I think just having
it on the emblem and the versus screen
is good enough and I think at least to
me
they justifies the tier 100 award
because it is something unique that
we've never had in the game before
another thing I was hearing was a lot of
people talking about the grouping of
certain effects and emblems just like we
were just
sing about the executions and personally
I totally agree I think it's a little
bit annoying that majority of the pass
is actually kind of the same content
like the truce of LIBOR and Dale emblem
now I understand there are three to four
unique emblems and that's totally fine
but for in specific truce of wyvern Dale
to one of the four emblems you get is in
the past four times for each of the four
factions personally to me I feel like
that should have been grouped together I
understand that they have to somehow fit
stuff into the battle pass and there's
only so many things you can do within
the limits and stuff that you have of
your game and I totally understand that
but as a person who is playing the
consumer I like everything to be grouped
up at one time I'm not saying that every
single truce of wyvern Dale emblem which
I like I said I think are three or four
of them they all need to be on the same
thing that's not what I'm saying I just
think that all truce of wyvern Dale
number one symbols should be all on the
same panel and number two should be on
their own thing not the Vikings version
is at tier three the Knights at tier 17
and it's all spread out it should all be
in the same exact tier so you get
everything right away especially because
it's kind of really not justified where
those types of items should be one thing
I really look for in a battle pass is
the kind of uniqueness and where it
should belong with that specific item
I'm gonna reference halo again with its
haunted helmet it was a thing back in
the old days not many players had and if
you saw it it was very unique and very
rare which justifies it being in each
tier 100 because it is technically one
of the rarest things in the game so it
should be the very last thing you will
mock whereas something from the default
character should be right up in front
and this is fair and they kind of did
this with the weapons actually in terms
of grouping which I did point out in my
video as well the actual weapons were
grouped up by groups of class and then
by year the first weapons that you'll
that you'll be seeing our warden Rader T
on D and Ken se which are each of the
main factions vanguards then it's each
of the facts and assassins then the
hybrids and then the heavies and then
after that is the year one heroes you
start to see Centurions shinobi
gladiator are emotion all the year one
DLC characters and then the last four
weapons are the year three which is why
soon dot in your are up in the 90s even
though they had just got released you
might think it's a little bit
the only issue with that of course is
that there really is no way to justify
why soon DAWs is 95 but warden is ranked
- maybe it's obviously it could just be
because of when they were released in
the game and soon died was the newest it
makes sense but at least it has an order
some of these color swatches and emblems
really don't justify why they're there
why does the Vikings emblem of the truce
of why Verndale at tier 3 with the
Knights being like in the tens and the
20s and higher what's the difference
there in terms of the actual quality
though of what the emblems and the
colors look like I set it in my video
describing what the 100 tiers are I
think the colors are really cool they're
not gonna fit with everybody style but I
think for the people that want those
those will definitely fit the weapons
are gonna really give off that edgy feel
and I feel like next season might be a
little bit different because you know
these weapons are all black and spiked
it would really fit for a lot of edgier
characters which is a big majority of
the armor we have in this game and in
terms of the signatures and executions I
also think that is really really cool as
well and I also think just from a
quality perspective they did a really
good job they're very unique and I think
they definitely deserve a place in the
Battle Pass the other thing a lot of
people were discussing especially some
hate towards is what the free pass has
and what the premium Pass has and why
some of it should actually belong in the
free pass the biggest thing I saw was
that the premium pass should not have
Salvage now each the premium pass and
the free pass do have Salvage and they
also have steel in there as well but the
values are different for the free pass
it's a hundred steel and 75 Salvage
whereas the premium it is 300 steel and
100 Salvage and I couldn't understand
that too a lot of people are mentioning
that you could actually salvage and
dismantle armor form or Salvage and
you're actually getting so bumping up
the salvage number I think would still
justify it to keep it in the premium
version and then maybe increase the one
in the free pass but not too much to
where it's completely use this does this
mantle gear because you can just get it
from the pass but I think it has to be
high enough because if it's not if it's
low enough like it is now no one's
really gonna really bat an eye to it I
have like in the 40s 50s 60000 s of
salvage and I know there's a shitload of
people who are in the hundreds of
thousands it probably somewhere in the
millions an extra 100 isn't gonna do you
[ __ ] overall for my recommendations of
the Battle Pass which of course this is
just my head in there
may not work out but I think stuff like
XP boosts steel salvage and stuff like
that should definitely go in the free
pass because that is just kind of
content that we've always gotten before
you complete a game you get steel you
eventually get an XP boost from the
challenges like the weakened ones and
the event orders and you get salvaged
from dismantling gear it's stuff that
players already have access to so why
not just give them a little bit more
with the free pass whereas the purchase
pass or the premium pass should have the
stuff that doesn't always come that
often you know the color swatches you
get by buying outfits or getting a
certain rep the weapons you get by
hitting a certain rep on the character
and getting a different rarity of items
effects executions and signatures that
you have to buy with said steel anything
like that should definitely be in the
premium pass although like I said it's
totally up to everybody's decision but
that's just how I see it and that's how
I've always seen it with battle passes
now for the very last section which is
gonna be a little bit more brief than
what the original and the first section
of the video was but the second section
is about the mechanics side and like
I've stated in the video previous to
this one there is 300 points per tier
and that means about 30,000 points I
believe my math is correct for all 100
tiers and at the current moment I'm like
20-something I think I'm close to 30 so
I've been grinded a bit and I bought in
a couple tears as well to kind of see
how both of those situations work out
and I think both of those in the
purchase amount that you need for those
I think is completely justified so I'm
totally cool with that and in terms of
earning them without actually having to
pay for the tears it really doesn't cost
you a whole lot to do like I've stated
in that past video you play a couple
breech games and then do the two daily
orders and you could be done within like
an hour too and you've already gotten
the rank and it's easy as that this is
one of the more interesting battle
passes out there compared to other games
a lot of games really like to hammer
home that the very easy levels are in
the front and the harder stuff is going
to be very hard to get at in the back
and that's why it takes a while years of
war is a big culprit of this where it
takes two or three stars or so to rank
up but as you get to general it takes
about 25 and while that isn't incredibly
hard to get there's definitely a show of
increasing how much work you have to put
in per rank which can maybe stop players
from grinding whereas for honor seems to
be this consistent 300 battle past
points and I think that's fair because
it keeps
same level of grinding and you're
getting rewards at an equal pace that
you're normally used to which i think is
totally justified
it's a finally in the video i wanted to
give my just overall thought of yes or
no pretty much of whether I enjoy the
battle pass and I got to say yes I kind
of enjoy it so the one big reason why I
enjoy it is actually because the price
point being ten dollars last year with
year three you had to buy the whole year
pass for forty dollars and you got
access to future content but that's the
real thing about the future you never
really know what's gonna happen if you
were me like many other people as well
that bought it when black prior came out
you had to hope that he's opre soon died
you're and we're gonna be good
characters what's the content within
that year justifying the forty dollars
that you bought right away with this you
can look at the year for season one
battle past say now this stuff sucks
[ __ ] off and not buy it but when year
for season two comes out with their
battle pass and might look even better
than what the original was and might
actually make you want to buy it and
then all you have to do is spend ten
dollars as opposed to spending forty
dollars for the entire year you're
effectively paying ten dollars per
season which is the same amount if
you're paying the whole fourteen you
know for all four seasons but you could
you don't have to pay that forty dollars
you can do maybe ten if you really just
liked one season every other season like
the season that has the hero or stuff
like that I think that's why I actually
kind of enjoyed the system because it
gives people a the availability to you
know maybe I don't want to spend forty
dollars because I want to kind of see
how this season's content is stacking
and then go from there and I think
that's why I really enjoy it this much
I've said it in my past videos but as
always let me know your comments about
the battle pass down below I've done a
couple polls I've seen in the comments
it does seem that the community is more
heating towards like that negative side
of this battle path sucks there should
be a lot more free things in the battle
path and obviously there's not going to
be an update to the current battle paths
that we're using that's already said and
done it's been released they probably
won't be able to change it yeah as
always let me know what your guys
thoughts on the video is in the comments
down below like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today
with everything happenings in the world
of foreigner and ever miss out on an
update that visa subscribe the channel
guys take care have a girls today peace
out and goodbye
[Music]